へいへい
あああああ
みなさんこんにちは
オールズコンサルティンググループの羽生田です英企業政府 npo
それぞれのいい経験を生かしてサステイナビリティ戦略に取り組んでいます
気候変動対策が必要だとこんなことみんななんとなくわかってるんですが
気候変動の話をするとき私いつも経済活動が悪いとか全部企業のせいだとか
こういう語り口が好きではありませんこれ聞こえ方によっては
じゃあ企業全部なくなっちゃった方がいいのとこんな風に聞こえるわけですねでこれ私
が経営コンサルタントだからとか
経済が大事だからとか
こういう理由で言ってるんじゃないんですこれ地球の置かれている状況を考えると
もう企業産業という
まあとパワフルな悪者にですねなくなってもらうようなもう余裕はないんですね
こういう企業産業というパープルなプレイヤーにこれからヒーローヒロインに
生まれ変わってもらう必要があると
これが地球の置かれている状況だと思っています
具体的に言うと温室効果ガスの排出をプラスマイナスゼロにするというカーボン
ニュートラル
これはもしかしたら企業が全部なくなったら少し近づい
二かも知れませんだけども
今まで出してしまった温室効果ガスを含めて回収していくカーボンネガティブの世界に
なると今度逆に企業が大きな投資をしてイノベーションをして技術をつくっていくと
もうこうでもしない限り実現できないわけですねまぁなので企業にはできるだけ地球に
やさしい地球の住民
なんかを目指すんじゃねぇ
来てできるだけ地球を救うドクター
こういう風になるまあ取り組むしてほしいと思っているわけです
ですけど残念ながらなかなか企業の活動ってそこまで本格化していないと今日はそれを
変えるための語り口
これを皆さんと共有したいというのが私のお話です
で
起業ぶっちゃけ楽しい日本の企業って結構可愛いそうです
なんでかというとへ
消費者がですね本気で気候変動
望むんだったら企業ですねそれに応えてちゃんとビジネスがまわってかつなんですが実
はそうなっていない
これ見ていただきたいのは何かというと国連が世界で40万人以上にとったアンケート
の結果なんですがこれ何かというと sdg 頭の中で
どれが大事ですかという質問です
で世界の人たちが応えたのが灰色の棒で日本が応えたのが好
茶色の棒です
でこれ見ると日本ってもうここですね
世界よりも2本の棒の方が高くなっているところ
目標で u 12十三十四とかその環境分野が大好きだとこういう風になってるんです
世界からすると日本は環境ばっかり大事にしているところはこんな風に見られているん
です
でも質問を変えて
じゃあ気候変動対策はあなたにとってどういうものですかとこういうふうに聞くとです
ね世界の人は気候変動対策すると生活が良くなるとこういうふうにワクワクするって
言っているのは大半の中で日本人は真逆です
聞こえの対策は生活の質を脅かすと思うという風になっている
なので十分
んじゃやりたくないなとこういう風に言ってるわけですねねぇ
まあもう打ち上げたらしい日本の消費者の聞こえインド対策というのは自己矛盾です
sdg 頭の中で環境だけが大事だ人権なんかにも大事だと言いながら自分じゃやり
たくないとこんな消費者を相手にしている
日本のマーケティング企業はですねまぁ
混乱の極みですなので
日本の企業が聞こえんどう大勢今季にやろうと思うと消費者の方ばっかり見ててもダメ
なんです
じゃあなに見なきゃいけないかというとまずは企業のうちなる
本音のまあ競争の話です
まああの経済産業は古い物差しでは勝てないって考え方なんですが
企業がずっとこれまで図られてきたまあまあ黒な gdp 1れてる gdp とか
国際競争力もともと日本を世界で1位とか2位だったのがもう今世界で30とかまで
落ちてるわけですね
方や
sdg ず達成度ランキングこういうのがあってこれ15位なんですが15微妙な数字
だなぁと思うかもしれませんがこの15位っていうのは少なくともフリー物差しである
gdp とか国政競争力よりはまだ
勝ち目がある数字というのを一つとこれよく見ると sdg ず結構ヨーロピアンが
作った世界
彼の中で実は日本ニュージーランドについてヨーロピアン以外だと世界になるんですね
なので少なくとも古いものさせてやる gdp とかそれのうち数である qcd
クオリティコスト納期ですねこういうもので見られるよりも sdc ずどれだけ
がんばってるので見られた方がまだ競争として勝ち目があると
こういうふうに企業の中でもまず認識してもらえたら行ってもいいです
もう一つが
問いが変わってきているという話に起用の中でまず考えたいと思っています
これまで企業へのといって
御社はいくら儲かりましたか次なるこういう競争に勝てますか
こんなのばっかり聞かれてきたわけですが今企業に対すると言って変わってきています
うまくというから東れていると言わ御社は10年後もあるんですかとこういうふうに
問われているわけです
我々実際に
ここ数年見てきました100年続いた一部上場企業100年企業がまああのガバナンス
の問題そして環境が変わった問題
これによって実際に倒産してみたり倒産しそうなので外資に買収されたり
の声を見てきたわけですまあですので企業は今必死になっています
自身何しているかと言うとアピールをしています
esg 投資環境社会ガバナンスこの観点での通してうちにしてくださいと統合報告書
というものを作っいっぱい作ってその中の価値創造ストーリーなんか言ってウチの会社
はこんなに世の中に価値を出していてこんなに求められています
なので安心してウチの会社に投資をどんどん続けてくださいって
こんな風にアピールをしているわけですただこれも実は十分じゃないんです
投資家だけ見ていてもダメなんですね
投資家だけ見ててなんでダメかというと投資家は先ほどの日本の消費者と違って別に
自己矛盾とかをしているわけじゃないんです
ですがぶっちゃけたらしい企業の普通の企業の中で投資家ってそんなに大事な存在じゃ
ないです
これ何かというといわゆる自分の会社に対する投資
見てる人って企業の中では正直本社の人だけですね本社の経理とか財務とか
ないした経営者本人とかぐらいしか党支持者に対する通して見てないわけです
まぁ出てくるは何かと言うと貸借対照表日バランスシートに出てくるので霧の中
貸借対照表日々見てる人ってそんなにいないわけですねねぇ
他方でまぁ企業の中で聞こえんど対策サステイナビリティの当事者増やそうと思うと
じゃあ誰の話にしなきゃいけないかというと事業部の話にしなきゃいけないんです企業
のほとんどの人は事業部にいるので事業部の話にする
っ気こうやって言うと多くの方がですねあ知ってるよとまぁサステイナビリティと事業
なしっていうと
お正サステナビリティを利益出しながらやる csv ken とか向こうドヤ顔で
コンセプトを言ってくるんですがまあそういう結果指標としての利益を出すなんとか
当たり前なんです
企業活動なんで借方と貸方を合わせるためには利益出さなきゃいけないのでこのあたり
前でそんな結果指標のコンセプトの空中戦はもう十分です今私がほしい
のは具体的なアクションですね今日皆さんと共有したいのが具体的なアクション企業が
明日からできる大きな変革ゲームチェンジャーとしての
調達ガイドライン急に舞台な言葉なんですがぜひこれ今日お大事な企業だとしてまぁ
好きになってほしいと思っています
難しい言葉で言うと企業が行動したいとしてできるルール形成なんて言い方をしたりし
ますが
調達ガイドラインすごく大事だと思っていますこれ何かというと企業
これ学校も同じですがガー
例えば材料とか道具とか買うときにうちの会社はこういうものしか買えませんないしは
こういうところからしか調達しません
こういう間ポリシーとか条件を変えたルールになります
これ法律とかなくても企業は自分で決めれるわけですね
でこれを例えばこういうふうに変えてください調達ガイドライン
当社は気候変動対策の目標を掲げて毎年進捗報告をしているサプライヤーからしか買い
ません
こういう風に言ったら変わると思わないですかどういうことかというとまあうちの会社
と取引したかったら気候変動対策の目標書く
受けて進捗報告しなきゃうち音と商売できないですよともうこういうわけです
で全部の調達品目にこれ広げてくれとは言いませんただ毎年ちょこちょこ所で同じもの
をそのコスト比較をして調達切り返しているようなものはどんどんこういう風に変えて
ほしいと思っています
よりリアルに想像していただきたいのがもしも明日
御社の一番大きな取引先がこれ言い出した時に恩赦耐えられますかと
これが非常に大事な問いだと思っていますなのでキーの中でぜひ調達ガイドラインを
どうデザインしていくかどう対応していくかこれ話し合ってほしいと思っています
もちろんも相談に
もなりますいうところです
最後にこれから起業をどういうふうに評価していったらいいかとその切り口の共有をさ
ようにしたいと思っています
でへ今気候変動対策企業大半の企業がほとんど do know her 6
ファームというのが意訳ですね極力階役にならないようにというまあその悪影響の排除
に止まっています
カーボンニュートラルなんかもこの範疇ですねでもこれだと正直
音車
すぐれちゃった方がなくなっちゃった方が悪影響事なくなっていいんじゃないのって
こんな風に聞こえちゃうんです
なのでぜひ高問題解決かをネガティブなんかもそうですが問題解決のところまで
踏み込んだし見綺麗になるだけじゃなくて課題を見つけて解決するところまで踏み込ん
でをしてというふうに思っていますこうすると大御社がなくなったら
世の中のこの課題解決が進まない存在意義があるともこんな
アピールにもなるわけですぜひこんな議論をですね
企業の中でどんどん進まぬでいただければ聞こえの大作のこの指とまれがどんどん進ん
で世の中が変わるとこんな風に期待しているわけです
またお話しましょう